today's day 62 feels like just yesterday
before we look at the numbers I just
want people to recall the context for
these numbers and remember what we have
accomplished we were faced with a
situation where the infection rate and
those numbers were going straight up
that was only 30 days ago that we saw
the number of cases a number of people
coming into hospitals the infection rate
everything was going straight up that
number would have just continued to go
straight up and that's why all the
projections national projections state
projections local projections turned out
to be incorrect excuse me because they
were all believing that that line was
going to continue to keep going up what
happened is New Yorkers Americans
changed reality literally changed
reality they literally changed the path
of the virus spread and reverse the
spread and that's what the closed down
procedures did that's what the masks
have done that's what the socially
distancing has done and New Yorkers and
all across this country
you saw that number change from that up
trajectory to the downward trajectory
that shift in the trajectory reduced by
about 100,000 the number of New Yorkers
who would have been in hospitalized
100,000 hospitalized to be hospitalized
you have to be seriously ill a portion
of those 100,000 would have passed away
so all this inconvenience all this
turmoil for what to keep 100,000 people
out of hospitals that's for what
and the 100,000 people into hospitals
would have overwhelmed the hospital
system would have been chaotic that's
where Italy was and a number of those
hundred thousand would have died so
remember that context and not just for
the retrospective but for the
prospective our past actions changed the
past trajectory our present actions will
determine the future trajectory it is
that clear it is cause and effect you
tell me what we do today I will tell you
the number of people sick tomorrow so
every day we get up every day everyone
says oh my gosh I have to do this again
yes but what you do today is going to
determine the number of sick tomorrow
and New Yorkers have continued to do
what they have to do and you see that
number of hospitalizations dropping and
that is all good news and that is a
credit to the community and the social
conscience and the responsibility of New
Yorkers the question now is as we're on
the decline how fast is the decline and
how far is the decline how low will the
number actually wind up right now we're
at about 1,000 new cases per day okay in
the 900s 954 933 979 73 that's four days
day before that it was 1076 that looks
like the number is flattening is
plateauing at about 900 1000 cases three
four days five days if you want to say
between 900 and 1100
too high a number of new cases to have
every day it's not where we were
a lot better than where we were for sure
but one thousand new cases every day is
still a very high infection rate it's
still a burden on the hospital system so
we now want to take it to the next level
let's drill down on those 1,000 new
cases where are they coming from
why is the infection rate continuing
who's getting infected and let's get
more targeted in our response right
we're fighting this statewide but you
have to wage the battle wages of war on
many fronts it's a statewide battle now
that we have it basically stabilized and
on the decline the enemy is on the run
the viruses is reducing let's get more
refined more targeted and I'm going to
be speaking with the hospitals this
afternoon and say that we want to get
more specific information on those new
cases that are coming in the door where
are they coming from who are they to see
if we can come up with a more specific
target if you look at the past few days
where the cases have been coming from
this is a three day with a cold rolling
average but you see 17% from Manhattan
much of it correlates to population but
much of it also correlates with
downstate New York 17% Manhattan 17%
Kings 12% Bronx 11% Queens but then 10%
Nassau 7% Westchester Suffolk so it's a
downstate region and then upstate it's
Erie County
so give you a snapshot of where the
cases are coming from but we need more
specific information to have a specific
battle plan literally where do the new
cases come from
are they essential workers are the
people who are staying home
and getting infected by a family member
or the essential workers who are still
traveling and possibly getting infected
at work where do they work how do they
commute is this a question of getting
infected on public transportation we
just announced new subway buses Long
Island Railroad Metro North protocols
where in the state are these people who
are being transferred from a nursing
home what's their sex what's their age
what's their previous health status what
are the demographics let's get more
specific information from the hospitals
to see if we can come up with a strategy
that is more tailored to the reduction
of these 1,000 cases per day the number
of deaths 289 lower than it has been but
still tragic and terrible and all the
good numbers or the good news for me
every day this number just wipes that
all away we announced a statewide policy
for our schools we did it last March
18th we said that we were going to close
schools all across the state k12 and
higher education schools we waved what
was called the 180 day requirement which
was the state regulation that schools
had to have 180 days of teaching schools
then transferred to distance learning
programs meal delivery services
childcare options for central workers
that has actually worked out well not
perfectly we had to do it in a rush but
there are lessons that we can learn here
that could change teaching going forward
and teaching in these types of
situations going forward but it did work
basically functioned well and teachers
did a phenomenal job stepping up to do
this it was a hardship on everyone but
we made the best of the situation
colleges and universities were also
moved to distance learning campuses were
closed unless the student really needed
housing on the campus schools obviously
by definition have higher density they
have transportation issues kids who are
getting on a bus we didn't have the
protective measures to put in place you
have 700 public school districts 4800
schools in this state then you have
1,800 private schools 89 SUNY and CUNY
campuses 100 private colleges and total
is 4.2 million students so the decisions
on the education system are obviously
critically important we must protect our
children every parent every citizen
feels that we must protect our students
we have to protect our educators and
given the circumstances that we're in
and the precautions that would have to
be put in place to come up with a plan
to reopen schools with all those new
protocols how do you an operate a school
that's socially distance with masks
without gatherings with a public
transportation system that has a lower
number of students on it how would you
get that plan up and running we don't
think it's possible to do that in a way
that would keep our children and
students and educators safe so we're
going to have the schools remain closed
for the rest of the year we're going to
continue the distance learning programs
schools have asked about summer school
and whether we'll have attendance in
schools for summer school that decision
will be made by the end of this month
again nobody can predict what the
situation is going to be three four
weeks from now so we're trying to stage
decisions at intervals that give us the
information but also enough time for
people to make the preparations they
need to make so any decisions on summer
schools will be made by the end of this
month
but in the meantime meal programs will
continue the childcare services where
essential workers will continue and then
we want schools to start now developing
a plan to reopen and the plan has to
have protocols in place that incorporate
everything that we are now doing in
society and everything that we learn
we're going to be asking businesses to
come up with plans that safeguard
workers when they reopen we need schools
to come up with plans also that bring
those precautions into the schoolroom
and that's for schools that's also for
colleges and the state will approve
those plans related issue that we need
to discuss and we need to pay attention
to this Colvard crisis has caused
significant disruption and many
unintended consequences and ancillary
issues that have developed and one of
them is when you have people who are put
in this situation immediately with no
notice it has caused serious mental
health issues you have anxiety
depression insomnia loneliness that
feeling of isolation we're seeing the
use of drugs go up we're seeing the use
of alcohol consumption go up this is a
chronic problem if you're feeling these
issues you're not alone as a matter of
fact half of all Americans have said
that their mental health has been
negatively impacted don't underestimate
the stress of this situation and it
happens on a lot of levels three out of
four say that their sleep has been
affected you don't know where that your
next paycheck is coming from you don't
know if your job is going to exist
you're at work one day the next day they
say everything is closed
stay in the house you're in that house
in a confined situation or you're in an
apartment in a confined situation you
can't get out it's difficult for
emotional support we have a hotline that
is set up people shouldn't be shy in any
way or have any second thoughts about
calling for help
it is a pervasive problem and people
should make the call and get the help if
they need the help we also see in line
with what we're talking about a dramatic
increase in the incidence of domestic
violence there was a fifteen percent
increase in March a 30% increase in
April that's March is when they started
15 percent April 30 % that is a
frightening rate and level of increase
again
New Yorkers in need we have a domestic
violence helpline 844 997 2121 you can
call just discuss the issue you don't
have to give your identity you don't
have to say where you live but people
who need help should reach out there was
no shame in reaching out and saying I
need help this is a national epidemic
it's a statewide epidemic ask for help
and we're here to help we're especially
concerned about these issues for
frontline workers I mean just think
about what the frontline workers are
going through think about what the
health care workers are going through
they're working extended hours they're
seeing a large number of people die
they're working in very frightening
situations they're worried about their
own health they're worried they get
infected they then have to go home
worried if they're infected are they
bringing that infection home so this is
a terribly stressful difficult time
especially for the frontline workers and
we want them to know that we
not only appreciate what they're doing
but we're there to support them right
saying thank you was nice acting in
gratitude is even nicer so we have a
special emotional support hotline for
our central workers and we're also going
to direct all insurers to waive any
cost-sharing co-pays deductibles for
mental health services for essential
workers which means the mental health
services will be free for frontline
workers and there'll be at no cost and
too many people too many families have
said to me well you know I would go for
services but I don't want to pay the
cost I can't afford it I don't want to
take that money for my family that's
gone there is no cost to get mental
health services so just wipe that reason
away and get the help that you need it's
even on if it's even in the best
interest of your family
last point personal opinion who said
when life knocks you on your ear learn
grow up and get back up was that Ajay
Parkinson who was not Ajay Parkinson it
was me nobody ever said that just me
when life knocks you on your rear
thought that dot learn grow and get back
up this has been a very difficult
difficult situation for everyone but
when life knocks you on your rear learn
and grow and we will collectively learn
and grow where we're gonna learn many
difficult lessons from this situation
we're going to learn about public health
threats that we never saw before we
never heard of we never really
anticipated we never actualized everyone
talked about global pandemics and that
possibility but you know what until it
happens people don't really get it
our hospital system and how that works
and how it works in an emergency hotel
education works out telemedicine works
how you keep society functioning during
an emergency how you communicate to
people the dangers of a situation
without panicking people because you
still need essential workers to come out
and do their job you don't want to panic
people where they say I'm not leaving
the house but you need to communicate
the facts so people act responsibly how
do you do that in a short period of time
what do you do about public
transportation you learned a whole
lesson with the downstate public
transportation system so there'll be a
lot to learn from this which we will
learn and we will be the better for I
believe that and that's that's part of
life in the meantime we have to go day
to day and we try to make the best of a
bad situation you try to find that
silver lining through the dark clouds
all of us try to do it in our own way
everybody is struggling with it in their
own way and that's all across the board
in many ways this is the great equalizer
it doesn't doesn't matter who you are
where you are this impacts your life
dramatically
but personally if you work at it maybe
you can find a little silver lining I'm
sitting there last night with my
daughter Mikayla she's my baby the baby
is now 22 and she says to me you know
that think about it
I've spent more time with you now then I
will probably spend with you in the rest
of my adult life I said wow what does
that mean she said well think about it
I've been with you for over a month I
won't be with you for another month for
the rest of my adult life which is kind
of jarring because I still think of her
as my baby but you
that's probably right you know she's 22
she's gonna go off to whatever she does
and then you see her at holidays for a
few hours here maybe you steal a
Saturday once in a while
reminded me of the Harry Chapin song
cat's in the cradle which was a great
old song from a great great man great
New Yorker too but these are with all
the bizarreness I haven't been able to
see my mother in two months but I have
my daughter probably for a longer period
of time than I probably have for the
rest of her adult life that's probably
true so you try to find the silver
lining you try to stay positive we stay
socially distance but we stay
spiritually connected New Yorkers have
been so supportive of each other you can
feel it there's a spirit of community
and mutuality people are there to help
one another people understand that
everybody is going through this
everybody's in stress you look at the
way people have complied with these
rules as annoying as they are masks
six-feet this that's out of respect one
for the other
I love the metaphor of the mask the mask
does not protect me I wear the mask to
protect you what a beautiful sign of
caring of mutuality I wear a mask to
protect you
that's that's the spirit even in this
terrible time of difficulty so yes you
can be socially distance but you can be
spiritually connected and closer in ways
you've never been before and I believe
that's where we are because we are New
York tough
which means tough smart United
disciplined and loving questions
[Applause]
they're reopening plans could states
start to Rio could school's start to
reopen as early as its fall possibly
sooner and we're hearing that New York
City their teachers are looking at
remote learning possibly in the fall so
I just learned about the timeline of all
this and what could happen at the
earliest there will be no opening of any
school in the state for the remainder of
the academic calendar year we have to
decide on summer school that decision
will be made by the end of May there is
no decision on the fall because the fall
is a long time depends when they're
going to open but they should start
preparing their plans now because this
is going to be a real exercise you know
we're talking about how manufacturing
companies socially distance how
construction companies socially distance
how does this school socially distance
you know this bizarre set up here right
look at this room how do you run a
school like this
how many more rooms would you need to do
this
how many more buses do you need to
socially distance on a bus you know
there's a whole how about a cafeteria
there's a whole set of questions how
about a dorm room so they should start
working on those plans now
I mean kids are kids they're gonna want
to run around and be together as well if
that VAT is a very good question Karen
and that's what we you know talking to
people all across the state educators
all across the state you can come up
with a plan which is by the way very
hard right they talk about spatial
requirements if you did this if you
require this in a classroom how many
more classrooms would you need in a
building right but then there's the
other question of K to 12 and then how
do I get students not to socially
distance you know how do you tell a
ten-year-old though it's socially
distance so we're gonna err on the side
of caution now that's for the rest of
the school year summer school you would
need to see in my opinion a drop in the
or stabilization of the infection rate
for a period of time because kids are
going to be kids I think you're right
well you couldn't get to more classrooms
anyway right you couldn't build more
classrooms in a way that would have any
difference for summer school or for the
Fall and money is going to be tight
depending on what Washington does and
they're doing remote learning you know
the fiscal consequences are going to be
mixed because of this period some ways
they save money some ways it costs money
sorry to harp on this but do you do you
anticipate a decision on on pause this
week again in terms of businesses May
15th is the decision on pause so you put
will you announce it prior to that or
will announce it prior to May 15th and
also just tough just to follow up it's
been two months since the first case was
reported you spoke today of what we have
accomplished and yet there's 18,000
people dead at least over 300,000 people
sick how would you evaluate your perform
during this crisis tried my best well
whether we're aware of what New Jersey's
doing with Connecticut's doing we're
trying to coordinate with those states
I've said from day one the you will not
have uniform policies across all the
states but knowing what other states are
going to do because the state can have a
significant effect on a neighboring
state knowing what they do is helpful
and then at the appropriate time we'll
make those decisions the decisions
around summer activities are very
difficult you want to look at the
tension you want to get people out of
their homes give them something to do
but you want to keep the infection rate
down you have these mental health issues
you have domestic violence issues you
have a lot going on so you do want a
relief valve right it's going to get hot
in the summer hopefully and you want to
have a level of activity you don't want
to overwhelm a neighboring state by
keeping everything closed but you don't
want to have high density and violation
of social distancing so that's that's
what we're trying to work through for
the summer activities we have a little
more time and we're talking about that
now just Jessie to go back just go just
even go back to your question for
section I can tell you this New Yorkers
did an extraordinary job and reduced the
rate of hospitalizations by about a
hundred thousand and saved thousands of
lives so kudos to New Yorkers
they count around 100 suspected
coronavirus deaths the state only had
around 13 on hand they had bodies
outside in storage containers
is there gonna be an investigation into
that it's about a geriatric center and
is there a way that there can be more
investigation into some of these chrome
virus suspected deaths well we have the
joint effort between the Attorney
General and the Department of Health
that is going to investigate
systemically how nursing homes handled
this situation and specifically
individual problem areas that we've seen
in nursing homes so that will certainly
be part of the Attorney General in the
Department of Health investigation we
have 613 nursing homes we investigate
anything that comes up if there's a
concern we will go in there find out
report back I guess uniform way of
reporting these deaths there is a for
mother and sent your question there is a
formal process of how we go in to
investigate try to find out what
happened what were the events what could
we do to prevent that in the future and
we address you all of them and whether
it's tied to a hospital tied to the
nursing home or both just show you clear
on the facts now what we're doing you we
report hospital deaths and nursing home
deaths separately that's on the slide
every day the question we're now asking
the hospitals one of the questions that
I posed was someone transferred from a
nursing home to a hospital and then
passed away in the hospital and we want
to know that that's that's your question
and that is a good question and we're
going to be asking that today and when I
get on the phone with the hospitals I'm
going to ask them just that
protecting essential workers you're
disinfected subway cars and buses in New
York City we're hearing from essential
workers in grocery stores who tell us
they're overwhelmed by people who are
rushing to the store who are not wearing
masks who are not practicing social
distancing and so I guess the question
is should these stores be refusing to
allow customers in who are not wearing
masks and I don't know maybe it's a
legal question I don't know maybe
Melissa or Rob would know or we can
check look on the grocery stores if I'm
a private grocery store owner and we
have these social distancing
requirements in place and masks in place
I think unless the lawyers want to argue
with me if I'm a private grocery store
owner I would deny admission to a person
who is not wearing a mask you could
endanger my other patrons you could
endanger my employees I would do that I
don't know about the behavior inside a
store you know but I think the private
grocery store owner would be in their
rights summer school they will do remote
learning they have to continue to do
meals etc we're talking about summer
school attendance in the building
explain the discrepancy between the
nursing home reported deaths because as
a follow-up to Morgan's question that
specific spot there's only 13 reported
deaths from their sick from that nursing
home on the Cova tracker however we've
got a report that they had 26 446 deaths
specific to Kovan and then potentially
more in the 50s so what's what's the
explanation for that just
can see and what are the consequences
supposed to mean with this nursing home
burden it's called the Isabella
geriatric Center it's in Manhattan does
anyone know we asked we went back and
asked the nursing homes to provide more
detailed data what they were doing in
some cases and not others
confirmed plus unconfirmed cases so what
we asked them to do is go back and say
what we're confirmed and what we run
confirmed so sometimes an odd number is
higher because those are actually
unconfirmed cases that they put into
certain reporting we ask them for the
confirmed at first but to get at this
sense of what you're talking about which
is why is the number a little higher we
ask them do you also include unconfirmed
numbers in that as well and what we're
finding is they were in also including
unconfirmed so what we're doing is
putting together a dataset right now
that has it by confirmed by a nursing
home and unconfirmed like we were doing
with the others - but that takes a
little time to tease out from the
nursing homes this is coming directly
from the are there consequences in case
nursing homes and what are those
Commissioner as Jim mentioned there's
two parts of this but this is the
evolving situation of the day that's
coming in and we do track this if
there's a concern about specific nursing
home and what the numbers are we will
look into that as well to attest to the
fact that the numbers are true and
accurate and every report they submit to
us if the Commission at the Department
of Health finds that there was
intentional misleading or whatever they
can revoke their license they can find
them penalties under the public health
law they will send people and I think
under this specific instance the
department park will go in and
investigate this to see like we've done
with others as well sometimes as the
governor and others have said before
this was an emerging situation there
were mistakes made on reporting some
people reported deaths from December
that's a mistake other cases they were
if there's potential intentional
misleading the Department of Health will
investigate those and then do the
appropriate actions let me give you the
answer former attorney general they have
given you two sets of numbers right
couldn't confirmed Cova deaths
one number then unconfirmed possible
Cova deaths which is this vague category
maybe the person died of kovat but we're
not sure
so unconfirmed deaths which is a vague
category to define and hospitals are
doing the same thing by the way the
local governments have to submit
unconfirmed potential Cova deaths so
that's a little squishy by definition
and then I can I can see where there's a
vagueness in that category but they
submit these numbers under penalty of
perjury you violate you commit fraud
that is a criminal offence period so
they can be prosecuted criminally for
fraud on any of these reporting numbers
nursing home death nursing homes will be
like a fire through dry grass are you
concerned that there is this vast gap
between the reporting and also what is
the state been doing the past two months
to alleviate that or is it for you can't
you can't you can't confuse eight when
they put possible or probable or
unconfirmed cause of death that by
definition you're asking them a vague
question and they're giving you a vague
answer so there's not they could argue
that's not fraud because they did not
know you're asking them for cause of
death they're saying it's unconfirmed
it's possible it's probable but if they
misrepresented then you have a criminal
fraud case John
you've said reopening lifting the pause
of order will be done on a regional
basis as we shift into phase one
so why is it the school opening this
very school closure decision made on a
regional basis as well because it's one
thing to say you can figure out how to
socially distance in construction or say
you can figure out how to socially
distance in a manufacturing facility
with adults and you couldn't figure out
social distancing etc to say we're going
to figure out that plan and put it in
place in the next few weeks is virtually
impossible you know you can't you you
can't get just think of a school
facility right and again go back to this
room you have 30 kids in a classroom but
with social distancing you can only put
10 kids in a classroom okay then get
another three classrooms with another
three teachers I can't cafeteria at
lunch time I put 200 kids in a cafeteria
well now you can only put 70 kids in the
cafeteria so have them meet in six
shifts you know and figure all this out
and get it done in a few weeks
and make sure you don't make a mistake
because we're talking about children and
we're talking about them getting
infected and bringing a either getting
sick themselves or bringing it home so
the stakes are high well you during the
academic year you would need to get to a
full phase to the schools to be
operation right you can't say okay
everybody in this they go back to work
but the schools are closed it'd be very
hard for part of the workforce to do
that but you're at the end of the school
year anyway here in a few weeks right
and then you're in the summer months and
then the big question is going to be
September
are you ready to reopen the schools in
September and if you don't then you can
argue you're not going to be ready for a
full business opening if you're not
opening the schools in September I think
that's true first off I mean there's a
huge protest this time there's two
protests going on outside I know you can
hear this time because I can hear in
here so I wouldn't talk to them I wanted
to know what was going on one is reopen
New York State who you've already heard
from the other is citizen action New
York and they are asking you to cancel
rent I asked the organizer how how it
would be funded and she suggested that
you tax billionaires this is this idea
feasible and what is your response to
that group of protesters that are lined
down Washington yeah
you have protesters in front of this
building on a continuing basis do you
think these are protesters you know
there's several dozen you come when
we're doing a controversial bill we have
hundreds of protesters all filling the
entire building it's like the building
vibrates with the chants and that's in
some ways great that's democracy people
have an opinion last week
you asked about the protesters who
wanted everything open the other day you
asked about protesters who wanted
everything closed that's what you get
one day it's everything open one day
it's everything closed my point is I get
their political opinion I get the
political spectrum I hear them I
understand what people say liberate New
York open everything up I understand why
people say clothes everything you're
gonna kill my children you know so I get
the arguments and what I said is this is
not a political decision let's make a
decision on the facts etc
I get the people who say nobody should
have to pay rent I get that argument I
get the landlords who say in the
building owners who say if nobody pays
rent I'm gonna walk away from my
building and then it's going to be
vacant and I'm not gonna pay any bills
because if they don't pay rent I'm not
paying bills and then you're gonna have
collapse of buildings what what we're
doing is no one can be evicted for
non-payment of rent between now and June
period period if a person can't pay
their rent because of the situation they
cannot be evicted that is the law till
June that law is in effect till June and
between now and June we'll see what
happens we'll figure it out then we'll
figure out what we need to do we have
some of the information but this is now
going to be an extraordinary when I get
on the phone with the hospitals they're
going to say this is a an extraordinary
reporting requirement right you're at
emergency rooms that were overwhelmed
you had administrators who were
overwhelmed working 24 hours a day to
get this level of granular detail on
people who were walking in the door and
get it to us on a nightly basis this is
going to be a significant administrative
burden on them are they essential
workers there's no such thing as an
essential worker before this how do they
commute that's a question that I don't
think has ever been asked of a patient
before
you know if you are an essential worker
where do you work you know these are not
questions that the healthcare system
ever asks but since it's down to 1,000
new cases per day I'm going to say to
the hospitals I understand it's a burden
but it's 1,000 people statewide it's
only several hundred in downstate New
York I understand the burden the volume
is a little lower this is a little
granular it is more detailed than
anything you've ever done but it's
important for us to get it now so we can
come up with a more specific targeted
plan decisions will follow the regional
decisions whatever we do in that region
will apply to the summer